zwei mal deine sachen so also jetzt
seien diese sorgt mich in die kamera
hält die sind so sagt man politik hängt
blau gestreift wasser und malz bisschen
hilfiger sorgen sie einmal leise leute
was geht
ich bin dran ich hey was geht ab und ex
willkommen bei einem neuen video
heute habe ich wieder mein freund
christian dabei wir sind jetzt offiziell
zusammen
nein spaß auf jeden fall haben wir ja im
letzten video das ist schon so a drei
monate her war gesagt ja passt auf wenn
ihr bock habt dann machen wir mal den
boyfriend tag und zwar gibt ich hab ja
leider ich bin jetzt single jetzt das
heißt ich kann mit den käufen tag machen
mit wem ich will jetzt locker werden
zusammen nun ist das schwarz ist dass
wir nichts das ist spaß christian walz
und noel schicken um die halt machen wir
fügen alles ein hammer jetzt schon bevor
er auf jeden fall können wir sagen wir
wünschen euch ganz viel spaß mit diesem
video und falls er uns auch so sind die
nicht zu ehren die ich ihnen da ist auf
jeden fall noch nach oben
wir müssen aber ernsthaft aber antworten
wir haben ja eine frage ist natürlich
mal ganz simpel solche hilft euch die
stellen erstellen sie mir erste frage
ist ganz simpel
wo habt ihr euch kennengelernt hat sich
das beantworten
das war ziemlich genau vor mehreren
jahren einen marienkäfer gruppe ich weiß
in der marienkäfer gruppe und er war
auch in der marienkäfer dann da war ich
in der forschung unterwirft
das war so traurig und ich konnte aber
seit grundschule waren dann wieder
vereint und jetzt bin ich umgezogen ist
sind wir zusammen halt einfach aber
fernbeziehung muss 20 km
damit hier sehen
fast schon mal bei mir aber erstmal hier
fangen wir mal 2 ich bin ich bin ganz
ich weiß zwar nicht was es mit bolt von
teck zu tun hat aber dann hab ich was
denn jetzt darum wie sie es selber leise
es geht auch darum wie viel der andere
über einen weiß weißt du aber selbst
dann weiß dann bist du mir schon
ziemlich wichtig weiß du und ich weiß
auch dass eine chat name nicht christ
ich habe eben doch auf install fragte
weißt du dein tipp für aber ist christ
tian ein bisschen game der ist ja auch
schnell mal eine band damit ihnen können
wir sind wirklich aber er ist auf der
suche nach ja doch ich weiß dann nahm
alex ganz normal geschrieben und ich
meine mit zwei atx plus richtig ja auf
jeden fall hier sind auch mal die
snapshot namen eingeblendet und das
war's match etwas der du selbst in
boston im schnitt 400 meine story
gesehen
ok dann hast du das denn er braucht nur
aufmerksamkeit so nummer drei was tut
der andere am liebsten habe ich auch so
gedacht wenn ich das jetzt mit drei
arbeitsfelder ich finde ich die frage
aber deswegen machen wir das ja okay
jetzt los ein dumas am liebsten
youtube-videos machst du ziemlich gerne
wirklich du hast du mal fußball gespielt
aber jetzt weißt du was du am liebsten
mag ich mache jetzt erstmal mit fenstern
für slapshot das macht dann ist ja noch
nicht am start ist er hier mit ich will
ich will ja nicht sagen i nicht
übertreiben normal können sie punkten
okay ist nicht viel sind nur einen
90.000 punkte auf snapshot deswegen
würde ich mal sagen nächste mal
junge junge für das hat die geister
privatsphäre ja aber hauptsache snapshot
öffentlich machen hoffentlich hält mich
auf skepsis
ich mache das aber nicht ihn nummer vier
lieblingsmusik natürlich am liebsten
justin timberlake - auch da kriege ich
das hat er einfach mal gesagt weil ich
einmal das habe ich nie gesagt natürlich
hat das neue lied von justin liebt meine
lieblingsmusik ist alex lieblingsmusik
ist das habe ich vor drei jahren gehört
also mit ich will nicht auf dem neuesten
stand
es gibt zwar nicht schatz justin bieber
auch mal in die zeitung gehört beinahe
sehen so aus als hätte ich irgendwie
eine steckdose gepackt oder schäumen die
kommentare die halt mal meine haare
sehen aus wie steckdose gepackt was
findest du am anderen am besonders sind
deine augen alter eine augen
ich liebe deine augen lange wimpern in
dem kindergarten winter ohne witz sein
den wimpern sind so lang in wirklichkeit
das sieht nicht jeder damit die
europäisch wird jetzt aber wirklich
deine socken gefällt mir mal einer sagen
zeig mir deine hand meines offen so
jetzt eine solche kamera handy sind so
sagt mein politischer die sensoren hängt
blau gestreift was ihr genehm und falls
es ein heftiger sorgen sie am reisetag
okay ich mag deine socken gerne die pink
lila beschreibt die sind nicht billig
man jeden die nächste gute die nächstes
richtig los mit den socken reihen nimmt
wie oft es damals schon fremdgegangen
ja
so was kann ich eigentlich nicht rein
aber ich bin ich eigentlich so ich bin
eigentlich nicht so einer aber du bist
mir das habe das habe ich weiß nicht
aber schon auf das wir fremd und ich
habe aber auch nicht alles raus bekommen
glaube ich heute mal wieder habe er ist
schon okay wenn er so zweimal die woche
des ok ist in ordnung so sagen sie
hübsch ist war es meine freunde die
hübsch ist dann findet das auch nicht so
schlimm aber ich finde das wirklich so
gut dass wir alle wie viele follower hat
der andere auf instagram das kann man es
nicht sagen was ich das immer verändern
aber zurzeit ich würde mal sagen
nach diesem video hast du so an die 4000
oder weltlich verwenden ich komme mir
wetten wenn nicht werden dann kriegen
wir er hat nach dem video 4000 noch
einer sagt wenn du hast nach dem 20.000
da hab ich ja das kommt für drei tage
danach aus über 4000 also wir gucken
dann musst du mir da mussten wir essen
ausgeben
ich muss hier wirklich einiges zusammen
essen zum candlelight dinner ist
bescheid
du musst du hast mal sechs falsch und
das kochen falsch
fast schon 19 ich mich vorlesen einig
doch jetzt schon die letzten zwei nummer
der mann die nummer 8 jetzt selber bitte
leise wobei euer erstes date ganz schwer
als im kindergartenalter nie getroffen
jeden tag hat doch ich weiß dass erst
mal als wirklich mich mit alles
getroffen haben wo ich ihn auch gefragt
habe ob man sich mal treffen war er hat
gesagt direkt bei mir
dann hat er mir gitarre vorgespielt hier
könntest du heute akkorde spielen junge
du machst dir schule gewusst
er wollte so vorspiel so ebbing super
läuft er kommt mit seiner e-gitarre lebt
bisher an den breiten darum dass das war
richtig romantisch lehrerin hat mir
eines dafür gegeben nicht locker nein
heute auf jeden fall hat auf jeden fall
spaß gemacht gerade zu drehen doch nicht
werten die normale junge frau das video
geht locker gehen auf jeden fall ob mir
natürlich dass wieder aufgefallen dass
auf jeden fall die daumen nach oben
dann machen wir jetzt hier ab und zu mal
wieder öfter was zusammen weil ich ihn
ja so gerne und auf jeden fall bei den
starts war mein mainz natürlich auch in
der video beschreibung abonnieren nicht
vergessen ich würde schon sagen schau
aber auf der linken seite geht es weiter
mit meinem letzten video keine ahnung
was der zweck dass auf ihn ab und hier
auf der anderen seite mit dem letzten
stein und yahoo